so we've been talking about the
anti-vaccine movement for I don't even
know four years since Pat was a little
kid at this point I think is fair to say
but we've been talking about it a lot in
2019 as well because the World Health
Organization has actually listed anti
vaccine sentiment as one of the top 10
global health threats of 2019 and the
reason that it is now a world health
threat rather than just the US is that
there are sort of nodes of anti vaccine
sentiment in the broader anti-vaxxer
network all over the world so in the
u.s. you've got Oregon and Washington
you've got a particular part of North
Carolina that is plagued for not using a
pun but it's plagued by anti vaccine
sentiment Italy has been a focal point
Japan we talked about last week or the
week before we talked last week about
Waterloo Ontario and Canada there's many
of these nodes in the anti-vaxxer
Network and I'm not going to bore you by
rehashing every single one of the
stories that we've done from each of
those places but I do have a new one to
add for you today which is from Italy
Italy has a I think it's not an
exaggeration to say a large anti-vaxxer
yet vaccination rate according to the
World Health Organization is 95% Italy
actually got down to 80% at one point in
time before they decided it's time for
us to take some action here 95% is
important because you need 95% for herd
immunity to function properly and the
concept of herd immunity I know a lot of
people know this is that when enough
people are vaccinated even unvaccinated
people are mostly protected because you
have most people protected which
disrupts the chain of infection and it
makes it mathematically unlikely that
someone who's unvaccinated because of a
medical condition for example or for
whatever reason will come in contact
with someone who is infectious and pass
along the disease that's the sort of
concept of herd immunity Italy has now
banned children under
from public schools in Italy unless they
have valid exemptions from vaccinations
if you send your unvaccinated kid to
school who's between the ages of 6 and
16 you can be fined up to 500 euro which
is about 560 dollars at today's exchange
rate and this is all because of
something called the Lorenz in law the
Lorenzen law says that children who go
to public school must receive vaccines
for chickenpox polio measles mumps and
rubella before they are allowed to
attend school and since the law was
introduced vaccination rates have
actually started to rise again from that
roughly 80% bottom out rate which is
really bad I mean that means one out of
five kids is not vaccinated you're not
even close to herd immunity at that rate
and now Italy is saying stop sending the
unvaccinated children to school so once
again they're sort of like two
categories kids up to six years old and
kids between 6 and 16 if you are six or
under you can't go to school without
proof of vaccination period if you are 6
to 16 you're not banned but your parents
get fined and 500 euro is a it's not
nothing let's put it that way
different regions of Italy are sort of
handling the law differently in bologna
letters of suspension have been sent to
300 children some other areas have
extended a grace period and you know
every time we talk about this pat we
start getting there's like I don't know
three or four different categories of
emails that we get we will get the
emails that focus on what they believe
is the lack of safety of the vaccines
themselves they say the vaccines
themselves are harmful sometimes they
will say they cause autism etc then you
have those who focus instead on the sort
of government mandate element of it's
saying governments can't
or at least shouldn't be mandating
specific medical treatments vaccines
being part of that and every time I
think it's important to mention Pat this
does not say that vaccination is in and
of itself mandatory it
mandatory if you want to send your kids
to public school if you want to
home-school them or send them to a
private school that doesn't have these
requirements with peace and love go
ahead and do that but this is not a
mandate that you have to vaccinate it's
the decision that if you want your kids
in public school
they must be vaccinated yeah and I think
that makes perfect sense because when
you decide to put your kids in public
schools you're giving up some of your
rights I mean you're taking part in
society and that's kind of what goes
along with it you have to follow certain
rules if you don't want to follow those
rules as you say you can homeschool your
kids you can put them into private
schools if you can afford it hopefully
it doesn't come to that hopefully these
anti-vaxxer parents will just cave and
get their children vaccinated and put
them in public schools so yes it doesn't
pin John people's freedoms but I think
in a totally reasonable way maybe
eventually we'll get to the point where
the anti-vaxxer movement has spread so
significantly that we'd have to talk
about mandatory vaccines for everyone
not just as it applies to public schools
but I hope we don't get to that point
because that would be a tough decision
to make yeah and it would be it was
legally problematic I mean it would be
different in different countries based
on how the law and constitutions when
they exist are written but I mean listen
we should not be in a situation where
that's even necessary let let's just
that we need an education campaign we
need to sort of take back the the the
misinformation that is being spread by
these anti vaccine errs and I hesitate
to even mention this other bit of news
but in the meantime yet another research
paper indicates that vaccines don't
cause autism and what I mean by I
hesitate to mention it is I don't even
want to admit to myself that this is
still something that has to be talked
about but I still get emails from people
saying vaccines specifically the MMR
vaccine causes autism we now have one
paper from dr. Andrew Wakefield who lost
his medical license a paper that has
been debunked because of its bad science
that says MMR is linked to autism and
now you have I don't even know how many
papers multiple serious research studies
including yet another one from the last
week or two which says there is
absolutely no evidence that the MMR
vaccine
causes autism in children or in anybody
and I've mentioned before that there is
left-wing and right-wing anti-vaxxer ISM
and for different reasons they've sort
of joined forces on the left you have
skepticism of Big Pharma catalyzing a
lot of anti VAX sentiment on the right
you have skepticism of government
catalyzing and coalescing some of that
anti VAX sentiment and you have overlap
people on the left and right saying I
absolutely agree with you about vaccines
being bad
but for completely different reasons and
it's interesting to see but interesting
is sort of the wrong term to apply
because it's also so so so destructive
and we will we'll see what happens with
the vaccination rate in Italy and we
will continue to follow this movement in
2019 which again was listed by the World
Health Organization as one of the
largest ten health threats it's optional
it's completely optional and yet it is a
serious health threat to humans